[Music]
our own cooking confidence coach Nanny
Bubby is back in studio thanks to
Chapman Automotive the sponsors of this
segment and today we are learning how to
make crispy Parmesan Ukon gold potatoes
that's a mouthful isn't it they smell
phenomenal but when it hits your mouth
it is worth the tongue pie for sure how
are you I'm doing great it's always good
to be with you here and always good to
be here for sure so these are Yukon Gold
potatoes and what we want to do is if
you can look at these here these are all
about the same size and the difference
between Yukon Gold of course and russet
is that the skin on the Yukon Golds was
really tender so you don't have to peel
them and when making this recipe the
reason that you want to make sure you
get all the same size is that when you
slice them in half crosswise right so
you take this and in half like this you
want them to lay in the dish all about
the same size okay okay so step one is
that you want to score the potatoes the
bottom slice them well yeah like that's
an Andy Bubby tidbit what does score
mean tell me okay so scoring means to
just make a slit right so we're going to
score it and be careful cuz you don't
want to get your hands the away yeah but
you want to make a slit just you know on
each this is so that the ingredients
whoop sip on down into it it's a little
bit hard I'll do this just cuz I don't
want you to have to bleed with your next
we have you don't want you to be
bleeding on your next interview turn it
into it's not Halloween anymore yeah
okay so now these are in the pan they're
ready to go and what we're going to do
is I'll let you do this okay so first
step is well I'll do this part we'll do
a teaspoon of salt a half of teaspoon of
pepper okay um we're going to do onion
powder okay that is smoked paprika okay
okay two cloves I put in three cloves of
garlic you can never have too much right
thir of a cup of Parmesan and then this
fabulous uh Rosemary which is a teaspoon
of Rosemary and I just this comes right
out of Nanny bubb's Garden I just want
you to that does smell
goodells yes an earthiness and so all
we're doing is we're going to make a
paste with four tablespoon of butter and
if you just want to start mixing that
yeah just go ahead and stir it okay okay
grab on there
okay that's it and then the next thing
we're going to do I'm going to take the
yeah there we are we're going to take
that's perfect now if the butter
congeals a little bit just stick it in
the microwave to soften it and what
we're going to do is we're using a
plastic spoon because Nanny Bubby's
kitchen is packed up cuz it's being
demoed so I couldn't find my spoons so
and we're just going to put this right
on the bottom so grab a spoon you can
help me do this really quickly and um
and these are pre-scored yes these are
all pre-scored and then just put them
upside down back down okay and as you
I'm sorry I just made a mess there
that's okay I made a mess with you and
you just paste this on just like this
mhm and this makes a great dish for
Thanksgiving because you can actually
make it the night before which makes it
great you can get it all prepared and
then you're going to stick it in the
oven at about 415 to 425 depending on
your own oven you know they're all
different um and um for about 25 to 30
minutes start
start to finish I'm sorry I dripped some
um we're making start to finish how long
do you think this takes so we're about
15 minutes in prep we're about 25
minutes in um baking but you know the
really good thing is that I never like
to say that this is a dish that's so
easy because I don't believe that things
really should be easy in the kitchen
because honestly like that's not what
food is food is not meant to be easy
food is meant to sustain us and we
should do whatever we have to do to do
that but at the end of the day
um this is very um non-complicated to
make so from here we're going to take
this and we're going to put it in the
oven little magic of Television coming
up here I feel it yes yes yes okay you
open or I'll open the door somebody open
the door here we go and we're going to
get this in thank you into the oven and
we're pretending this is about 25
minutes well it actually is take a look
at this yeah 25 to 30 minutes there we
go look at that is that beautiful so I
did find two forks in my kitchen so I
did bring those and fun thing is is that
in 2 weeks from now we're actually going
to debut Nanny bubb's kitchen here on
the air for Thanksgiving I can get this
out and you can see the bottom of it
look at that oh that looks delicious it
smells phenomenal there you go you're
still going to join us in our kitchen
too right yes well yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but just for just for that was a
one day thing and let's see if this is
done all right I'm going to toss I can't
wait to taste it after it cools off a
little bit but in the meantime uh of
course check out Nanny Bubby's kitchen
and Garden on social media and online at
nanny.com also want to thank Chapman
Automotive for sponsoring this segment
and we're going to try this out while
Ted tells us what's up with the weather
oh guys